welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and today our
guest is professor of Gustav Ranas he is
the Frank actual professor emeritus of
international economics at Yale and was
the director of the McMillan center from
1996 to 2004 professor Ranas has more
than 20 books and 300 articles on
theoretical and policy related issues of
economic and human development to his
credit he served as assistant
administrator for policy and planning in
a ID department of state during the
Johnson administration he is here with
us today to talk about his research on
the priority of human development
welcome professor Ranas I should be here
in your research you look at the link
between human development and economic
growth why is it important to look at
that well most of the past history has
been focused on economic growth but the
basic idea here is that course is really
a means to an end not an end in itself
people don't eat GNP they like long
happy healthy lives and human
development measures that dimension of
human welfare so the idea is to look at
the links between growth which is still
necessary as a means to the end of
increasing human development performance
okay and what are the major links
between human development and economic
growth well they're too kind to channels
one goes from economic growth to human
development and as a feedback from human
development back to economic growth so
if you measure human development as it
is done by the human development reports
of the United Nations its measured in
terms of things like infant mortality
literacy levels of education the things
that people really care about in terms
of their long and happy and healthy life
so you starting with ezio collate a
certain percentage how's that money
spent much of the spend on luxury goods
or consumer goods and serve it is spent
on things that produce increases in
human development who are the agents are
doing this they are the families there's
the government and there's sort of NGOs
third sectors and clearly you will
understand that families especially if
females are in charge of the allocation
rather than males like to spend money
for their kids education for the health
of their charter their babies in
particular infant mortality and literacy
and so how much is how much of their
income they spend on on these things
that is very important from the point of
view of that first channel since health
and education are public goods as well
as private goods the government is very
much involved both the central
government and if it's a decentralized
government local governments to one
extent or another spent quite a bit of
their money on things which produce
increases in human development any one
of those that have mentioned then
finally the NGOs who would spend most of
their energy and most of their money on
human development so that's the one link
from growth to human development then as
a reverse link when you have people with
better levels of human development they
are more capable of producing growth the
next period for example if you have
people who are healthier they are
producing their labor is more effective
for more efficient
entrepreneurs more active managers are
better equipped and combined with
investment rates you know capital
accumulation and capital and may come
from inside and savings of the society
itself together will produce more GNP in
an X period so the cycle continues and
so you have countries which are doing
very well both with respect to quote and
doing well with respect to enhancing the
human development levels okay and you've
looked at developing countries and
categorized them in specific ways
depending on these linkages can you
speak to that for a little bit and
describe them yeah there's have four
categories some countries can be
classified as being in a virtuous cycle
the virtuous cycle means that compared
to all the developing countries we're
dealing mostly with developing countries
not with the mature countries of each
country's that it compared to all the
other developing countries if they're
doing better than average on growth and
better than average on human development
column it being a virtuous cycle and if
they're doing worse than yeah which I'm
both called a vicious cycle and you can
probably imagine that the virtual cycle
countries are largely in sub-sahara in
the virtuous ones are in east asia and
the vicious ones are largely in
sub-saharan africa now the interesting
cases are the ones which should do
better than average on one but worse
than average any other and these are
kind of lopsided cases the countries
which do better than average on growth
and worse than average and human
development and vice versa and those are
the two kind of love started categories
which are quite interesting and we do
quite a bit of analysis on that because
the we find one of the interesting
findings is
it if a country is better than average
on growth but worse than average and
human development it's very hard for
them to graduate into the virtuous cycle
which ever i would like to be less the
promised land while the other way around
if you're worse than average and caused
by better than average and human
development you can graduate into the
Promised Land of the virtuous cycle okay
let's talk about some specific countries
has anyone reached the promised land and
then conversely as anyone let stuck at
the bottom so it is yeah quite a few are
at the bottom most of sub-saharan Africa
is vicious cycle all the way through
what we do is divide the whole period
from 1962 2004 i think it was in two
decades and see how they progress over
time and we find that some countries get
stuck vicious cycle somewhere virtuals
all the way through but the interesting
case that once that move and graduate or
fail to graduate any particular
countries that yellow china for example
China was for a while human development
lopsided in the faith in favor of human
development and they ultimately
graduated into virtuous cycle on the
other hand the other hand Egypt was
lopsided in favor of growth and ended up
in a vicious cycle for the time being I
mean there's always a chance for it to
recover but it seems to be true that in
order to recover you have to move
towards the human development
lopsidedness before you can get into the
promised land that seems no country we
found which is lopsided in favor of
growth and makes it into the promised
land and what are we looking at in terms
of time periods for a country to you
know move in one direction or another I
imagine it varies but is there any kind
of average well so he find it takes a
decade two decades they we've reaped on
this five decades and look at it take it
by decades see what's happening so we
not only see the whole period but also
the decade by decade and some countries
can shift from decade to another
sometimes they fall back they have a
crisis of one kind or another through
external shocks one kind another and so
you can't make it generalize about long
it will take but you can be sure about
what I said before which is that you've
got to move the favor human development
if ultimately you're going to reach the
virtuous cycle okay so in looking at
your research that would be one of the
conclusions are there any others that
you've reached through your work well
one of the main conclusions is that the
old idea which in the 50s 60s and 70s
people said let's go first and worry
about things like Medusa called social
elements later this research shows that
that's social sort of soft stuff is
really quite essential it's not soft
it's really hard and it needs to be
taking into account early on so you need
either you have to move together in both
directions or if you have no you have a
choice to make human development you
come first if you're going to try to
make it so that's the most important
conclusion the other conclusions such as
when it comes to how the money gets
spent focusing will take the families as
I mentioned earlier we find that this
other research has been done by a lot of
other people that to the extent that the
decision maker is the father the family
is much more likely to spend things on
not human development oriented goods
well if it's a female headed family or
at least the woman contributes to the
family income and has a voice and how
money is spent you're more likely to get
money spent on human
objectives another conclusion which is
partly our work and partly comes from
other work that we've we've looked at if
you have a decentralized government
rather than a centralized government
there's likely be more money spent on
human development because they are
closer to what people really need and
want which often is human development
that's what people don't the quest words
interested in okay and finally there it
seems to me policy implications that one
could look towards based on your
research and its conclusions can you
speak to that at all well I have already
done a bit of that in a sense that the
importance of literacy infant mortality
and life expectancy as in as an
objective of policy early on comes out
clearly from the research we've done and
as a huge activity now on this Human
Development Index which is a some way of
the various things I've talked about
which is not only on a global level
categorizing countries how well they
have done on human development but also
within countries you get state-by-state
comparisons it's like league tables
where people compete with each other to
see how they're doing and that's been a
very healthy result of the whole effort
started about the idea started in the
80s but since 1990 when the first human
development report was issued by the by
the United Nations this idea has kind of
taken the attention of policymakers both
donors and more interesting recipients
because recipients find this appealing
in terms of what people will want and to
think of human development as the final
objective you can go beyond the three or
four items I've mentioned
people like amateur sin at Harvard goes
into capabilities which is important
version of human development what makes
people happy it's not just the things
I've mentioned other things like being
left alone having freedom of choice
having freedom of religion all kinds of
other issues with record capabilities
but some of them I measurable someone
less measurable but the whole approach
to recognizing that that GDP of GNP is
only a means to a heavy long and
productive life is a big quake foo and
has affected policymakers both in the
recipient colors and in the donor
community foreign aid community okay
wonderful well thank you very much for
being with us here with us today and
sharing your research it's my pleasure
for more information about professor
Reyes and his work please visit our
website at yale edu backslash macmillan
report be sure to join us again for
another episode of the macmillan report
made possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale
you